every time we would run into well he
would be like 100 a day
and he started to do it and he lost like
a hundred pounds and it says it's all
good to me
pete davidson says alec baldwin can
trace his weight loss
back to one little lie he once told him
on tuesdays the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon the 27 year old saturday
night live star
opened up about the hilarious story
behind the 63 year old actor
getting in shape alec was hosting and it
was a sketch where i had to be shirtless
so he came up to me and he was like what
do you do and i didn't want to be rude
and say like i just still have
metabolism
[Laughter]
so i'm not
i'm not in my mid-50s i just wake up
like this
so i i to make him feel better i was
like
oh man i do 100 push-ups and 100 sit-ups
every day and he was like
got it yeah so the king of staten island
star
doesn't actually do 100 sit-ups and 100
push-ups a day
but alec he was inspired and then he got
uh the trump gig and so i would see him
every week and every time he would run
into a wall he would be like
100 a day and he started to do it and he
lost like a hundred pounds
yeah he looks fantastic yeah he's and it
says it's all good
confirmed the story during a 2019
interview on the howard stern show
pete davidson said do a hundred sit-ups
a day
and people have push-ups today you know
and i i do it now i do i do more i do
like 120 550 you build up
well if pete wants to get on alex level
he could totally have him over for a
sweat sesh
since the comedian has officially moved
out of his mom's basement
and into his own staten island pad he
confirmed the news during a recent
facetime interview
i just moved out of my mom's house yeah
i'm fully out
i got a pad and it seems these days pete
is thriving for many reasons he'll
appear in the upcoming film the suicide
squad releasing in theaters in august
it's a thing i still can't believe it's
like ridiculous my family and friends
like
it was the first time they ever got like
super excited for anything i've ever
done
and it seems he's found a little time
for romance too
with bridgerton star phoebe denover what
were you going to say
before you started to say something oh i
didn't have a call simon look at me
a source told et last month that the
pair initially met
at a gathering in nyc and really hit it
off
and ever since things have gotten a bit
more serious as they travel between new
york
and england to spend time together while
also working
[Music]